[Musique]
[Musique] [Musique
]
maintenant [
Musique
] [Musique] maintenant [Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
h
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le pont-levis Sam et au
ghv Mellin, notre base d'
opérations mobile, allez, je vais  vous aider à vous
repérer voici l'armurerie du navire
ici vous pouvez vérifier vos armes et les mettre à
l'épreuve
ces pièces ici appartiennent à d'autres
membres de l'équipage elles sont à peu près
les mêmes que
les vôtres et les douches à la
fin  C'est un sacré navire que vous avez
ici grâce à l'UCA. Je suppose que non, car
je vous l'ai dit, le pont-levis est une
entreprise civile, mais nous avons un patron généreux
avec accès à beaucoup de capitaux dans la technologie, cela
ressemble à un Big Shot de l'UCA.  Je ne me demande pas que
nous ne nous sommes jamais rencontrés face à
face, ils n'accordent pas plus d'importance à leur vie privée
que de croire que
[Musique]
c'est la même chose qu'en
Amérique, les gens ici sont tous
dispersés, coupés les uns des autres, nous voulons que vous
nous aidiez  rassembler le monde
Sam, cela vous dérangerait-il si je me rejoignais pour lui faire
plaisir,
ses connaissances et son expérience lui seront
probablement utiles plus tard
oui vraiment
Sam la
robotique et le fusil de
chasse Je préfère le siège du conducteur
Sam, tu me lis, tu devras d'abord y
accéder  le terminal de porte latéral du Mexique,
après avoir confirmé la
couverture du réseau, nous pouvons prendre le dhv Mellin et
regrouper votre
position. Le problème est que tout le monde ne
veut pas faire partie de l'UCA, ce
n'est pas le plan. Sam, l'UCA ne cherche pas à
se développer.  ses frontières, tout comme avec le Mexique,
ils veulent intégrer de nouvelles régions au
réseau de toute façon, le dhv melan est là pour
vous
soutenir, comme toujours, vous serez celui qui ouvrira
la voie pour étendre le
réseau, quel est votre rôle dans tout cela,
vous êtes le commandant  hein c'est vrai
ces jours-ci, je suis fragile de nom
[Musique]
seulement tu as réuni l'Amérique pour l'aider
à renaître sous le nom d'
UCA mais j'ai bien peur que la mort échouée soit
loin d'être terminée, l'
humanité est toujours en danger, toujours
au bord de
l'extinction, ne  Je n'agis pas comme si vous ne le voyiez pas,
beaucoup de choses ont changé après que vous
ayez quitté le vôtre, en particulier au sein de l'
UCA. Les ponts ne sont plus à l'étranger, le
réseau de distribution, ils se sont retirés une fois que
les choses étaient opérationnelles, donc vos
amis et collègues sont tous partis.
de manière séparée au sein de la couverture réseau, il n'est
plus nécessaire de compter sur des porteurs humains, donc après avoir fermé boutique, je suis allé
créer un nouveau groupe qui gère le
travail dans les régions en dehors de l'
UCA, nous avons décidé de nous appeler
pont-levis avec le soutien du
réseau kyal et  apass L'humanité sera libérée
du besoin de se déplacer Les
robots sont capables de gérer
les livraisons il est
vivant il s'est appelé un fantôme mais nous avons
trouvé un moyen de revenir de la plage juste pour qu'il
puisse
nous tuer il a dit qu'il était revenu pour se venger
de toi et
moi
hé frère, est-ce que je t'ai manqué
ouais, je pensais que tu rendrais visite à cet endroit
vu que j'ai
distribué les fruits de cette belle
usine sur tout le
continent, les armes et la violence, le
foutu monde entier pourrait être à toi comme
jamais
c'était
oh on dirait que tu as décidé d'échanger
cette corde contre un bâton pour faire le tour
mais je suppose que même un porteur doit appuyer sur
la gâchette de temps en
temps oh et
toi hé mon pote es-tu juste une autre
petite balle sans âme hein lâche-
moi pathétique  guitariste où est le reste
de ton
groupe euh euh euh
[Musique]
eh bien, n'est-ce pas
quelque chose, c'est toi, higs, hein, c'est toi
qui as tué
Lou, tu ne sais toujours pas, est-ce que tu baises
[Musique]
quelque chose qu'il a dit que tu ne faisais pas  Je ne sais
rien à propos de Lou, d'accord, Sam,
voyons ce que nous pouvons trouver sur
Lou si tu veux des réponses, tu devras
les trouver toi-même, mais celles que
tu trouveras feront que la douleur que tu soignes ne fera
qu'empirer Sam le  homme dans le
noir sur
tout,
n'oublie pas que venir dans cette expédition
était censé t'aider à trouver la force
de continuer et tu l'as,
nous savons tous que tu l'as maintenant,
il est temps de terminer le voyage
Sam, s'il te plaît, comprends
[Musique]
Sam  nous n'avons jamais eu l'intention de vous
enchaîner, laissez Crystal nous l'avons trouvée
à l'intérieur, il était rempli d'un fluide qui
contenait des acides aminés avec une
structure identique à celle trouvée dans
le goudron. Je suis désolé, il y a des acides aminés dans le
goudron comme dans
les protéines, bien sûr, comment faire autrement  tu
penses que des créatures carales pourraient en émerger
certains ont même théorisé que la
tour est une sorte de
soupe primordiale j'y étais je l'ai vue
chez moi c'était un
enfer tu vois après avoir quitté Bridges j'ai
décidé de faire un petit creusement maintenant
d'après  pour eux, le bb28 a été signalé pour
élimination, puis incinéré il
y a quatre ans, bien avant que vous et Lou ne
rencontriez
[Musique]
PlayStation pour la première fois.